[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800
83567 for7 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Jean Ross
Hello friends welcome to Bible answers
live let's start with an amazing fact in
1960 Leonard roganov a young Russian
surgeon volunteered to join a Soviet
Antarctic expedition as the team doctor
after a long journey they eventually
reached the remote Antarctic station
thousands of miles from civilization
where the team planed to spend the
several months doing
research but then April 29
1961 roganov began to experience
terrible pain in his abdomen which just
kept getting worse to his dismay he
finally realized that he was suffering
from acute appendicitis and he immediate
surgery was needed the problem was that
he was the only doctor at the base and
the nearest surgical facility was
thousands of miles away to make things
worse bad weather conditions made
evacuation impossible he was left with
no other option but to operate on
himself with the assistance of two
others neither of whom had any medical
training roganov set up a makeshift
operating room at the base and began a
2hour surgery on himself using local
anesthetic and a mirror to see what he
was doing roganov successfully removed
his appendix and he made a full
recovery well friends the story reminds
me of the biblical lesson that we need
to have patient endurance as well when
facing trials and
tribulations the Apostle James tells us
blessed is the man who endures
Temptation for when he has been approved
he will receive the Crown of Life which
the Lord has promised to those that love
James
1:12 remember friends that despite the
trials that you might be going through
today having faith in God and trusting
in his word will see you through every
trial and will lead to Ultimate victory
at the second coming of Christ that's
why Jesus said he that endures to the
end the same shall be saved well friends
I want to welcome you again to Bible
answers live my name is Sean Ross Pastor
Doug is out this evening but our phone
lines are open if you have have a Bible
related question we would love to hear
from you tonight our phone line here to
the studio is 800 463
7297 the number again is 800 463
7297 that'll bring you here into the
studio if you also have a email question
you can just email that to Bible answers
Live email at amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to get your email
sent to us as well we have a free offer
we want to tell you about it is a book
written here at amazing facts and it is
free for anyone who calls an ass it is
called death watch in Siberian it goes
along with our opening fact talking
about enduring trials and in this case
for Christ you'll be blessed by reading
this book it's free just call 800 835
6747 and you can ask for offer number
114 or ask for it by name Death Watch in
Siberia there's another way that you can
get the book just dial pound 250 on your
smartphone and say Bible answers live
and then ask for the book by name Death
Watch in Siberia we'll be happy to send
it to you if you're outside of North
America go to the website
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
download a digital copy of the book and
you'll be able to read that right now so
take advantage of that wonderful free
offer I see we've got some uh callers
waiting for um their questions but
before we go to the phone lines let's
have a word of prayer dear father we are
so grateful for this opportunity once
again to be able to open up up your word
and study these very important truths
from scripture Lord the Bible is your
book we ask for the Holy Spirit to come
and guide us lead us all into a clearer
understanding of your word for we ask
this in jesus' name amen well our first
caller this evening Janet Lee is
listening in New York Janet Lee welcome
to the program you're on Bible answers
live hi P how are you I'm doing well
thanks for calling ni I started to read
the Book of Jonah and listening to
stories and
M and seeing how uh Jonah was at the
beginning everyone was saying don't
punish me because of him and I almost
feel convicted as an American with
everything that's happening I was just
wondering if if this is just kind of
some Panic or you know if we should be
taking this a little more serious and
repenting yeah absolutely I Think Jesus
made it clear in Matthew chapter 24 he
gave us certain signs connected with his
second coming the Bible speaks of wars
and rumors of wars his pestilence
diseases uh all of these are are warning
signs but I think one of the greatest
signs that Jesus gives is that when this
Gospel of the Kingdom he said shall be
preached unto all the world as a witness
unto all nations then the end will come
so yes we see these things happening in
the world if anything I think it should
Inspire us and motivate us as Christians
to proclaim the gospel to the world now
that might be in your neck of the woods
in your neighborhood to your friends to
your neighbors to live out your faith
Faith because this gospel is go to all
the world and then the end will come and
that's happening through technology
through media through satellites through
the internet the gospel is being
preached to the world so yes the sign of
Jonah is absolutely one of those signs
could very well be the natural disasters
and the earthquakes that we see in the
world does that uh make sense Janet
Lee yeah yeah I'm seeing it I'm I've
just been feeling more called to tell my
friends to start picking up the book and
it's a good book it's an interesting
book it is a very interesting book it's
a great book because it also illustrates
the gospel not only is it talking about
warnings of judgment but it's also a
gospel invitation you see God's mercy
for those in Nineveh and actually
sending JN and despite his reluctance to
actually preach this warning message a
number of important lessons there thanks
for your call next caller that we have
is Gary and he's listening in Illinois
Gary welcome to Bible answers
live thank you in Revelation 13 it talks
of two beasts the second beast has
political and religious power like the
first Beast so my question is is this
second beast does it have anything to do
with the Christian nationalism movement
that we're seeing right now well uh yes
it does but let me just back up a little
bit and talk about these two beasts
Revelation chapter 13 you referring to
the first piece that's described
beginning in verse one and it goes
through until um verse 10 it describes a
beast that arises up out of the sea and
it talks about this beast and gives
descriptions now beast in Bible prophecy
represents a political power a nation
and in this case the first Beast
represents a political power but it's
Unique because it's got talks about it's
got blasphemy or blasphemies against God
so it's both a political and a religious
power it is sort of a combination of
church and state and Protestant
reformers throughout history have
identified this first Beast of
Revelation 13 as representing the rise
of the papal power or the Vatican
especially during the 1260 years of
papal Supremacy from 538 until
1798 but there is a second beast that's
referred to here coming up from the
earth and he had two horns like a lamb
this is verse 11 but he ended up
speaking like a dragon that second beast
has been identified as the United States
in Bible prophecy so as the first Beast
was receiving What's called the Dead
wound that occurred at the end of the
1260 years of papal Supremacy in
1798 where the political power of the
papacy was removed another Power was
arising well that power of course was
the United States it was gaining
momentum it was growing to World
prominence and the United States
different from the papal power was based
upon Protestant values uh the freedom of
religion separation of church and state
which was different from that of the
papal power of the Vatican But as time
goes on it says it has two horns like a
lamb but it speaks like a dragon meaning
there is a change that takes place
within the United States and I think
there's going to be a bit of a backlash
you might say to the moral Decay that we
see in our society those who are
convicted or feel like wow you know we
need to get America back to God and to
some degree we agree with them because
we see the sin and we see just the
immorality that's taking place around us
but you can't force people to worship
God it's got to be a Freedom of Choice a
decision they make however they're going
to go to extreme and eventually
according to Bible prophecy certain laws
will be enforce that restrict religious
worship and that sets up the mark of the
beast that you read about here in the
same passage so does those uh is does
the religious right or the Christian
Coalition or The ecumenical movement
that we see in the United States does
that have something to play in this I
believe so and I think as time goes on
we'll see this even clearer does that uh
does that make sense Gary well it does
really very a a whole lot all right well
thank you for your call you know we do
have um a study guide that we'll be
happy to send to anyone who wants to
learn more about the United States in
Bible prophecy it is called the US in
Bible prophecy pretty simple name if
you'd like to receive that just call and
ask the number is 800 835
6747 ask for the study guide It's called
the United States or the US in Bible
prophecy if you'd like to receive a
digital download of that study guide
dial pound 250 on your smartphone say
Bible answers live and say I'd like to
get the study guide the US in Bible
prophecy and you'll be able to download
that lesson right there next caller that
we have is uh Henry listening in New
York Henry welcome to the program yes
hello hi and your question my question
is uh when you
die doesn't matter where your body goes
when you die doesn't matter when you do
you mean if you're buried or crated
right I know when Jesus Christ died in
the Tomb when last di but if I die today
Tom it doesn't matter where my body goes
all right well that's a good question
yes well first of all in the
resurrection for the believer you know
they're going to be resurrected to
eternal life when Jesus comes the second
time are we receive at the second coming
of Christ whether we are resurrected
from the dead or whether we are alive
and changed in a moment in a winling and
ey we receive Immortal bodies very
different than the bodies that we have
now so God doesn't need anything of the
leftovers of this body that we currently
have in order for us to be recreated to
have our Immortal bodies so you know
from a Biblical perspective uh if you
look at the tradition that we see in
scripture most people were buried but if
you buried for a long enough time
there's not anything left but maybe some
teeth and a few bones uh again that's
not something something that God needs
to recreate you at the second coming of
Christ uh there are a few examples uh in
the Bible I'm thinking of Jonathan he
was eventually um cremated they gathered
his body and they burnt it uh of course
we believe that Jonathan will be
resurrected he loved the Lord he was
faithful and then of course there were
many Christian Martyrs throughout the
Dark Ages who faced persecution many of
them were burned at the stake for their
faith in God for their willingness to
follow the Bible and and we believe that
they will also be resurrected at the
second coming of Christ so does it
really matter no I think that's
something you might want to decide maybe
talk to your family and reach a decision
but from a Biblical perspective uh God
doesn't need any of these bodies when he
recreates us so uh hopefully that helps
Henry thank you for your call we've got
Jamie listening in Idaho Jamie welcome
to the
program oh it's so good to talk to you
thank you for taking my call you're
welcome thanks for calling my questions
how Revelation 3:10 okay where it says
because thou has kept the word of my
patience I also will keep thee from the
hour of Temptation which shall come upon
all the world to try them that dwell
upon the Earth and my friend is telling
me that this is belonging to the
pre-trib and the Rapture because he will
keep us from the hour of Temptation and
so we're not going to have to worry
about uh the tribulation we're going to
be we're going to be raptured off and
that worry about it so can you explain
this scripture to me yeah absolutely so
I can explain it to her yeah happy to so
when you look in Revelation Chapter 2
and three you have Christ's message to
the seven churches there's a series of
sevens in the Book of Revelation seven
churches Seven Seals and seven trumpets
and each of these series of sevens
represent the Christian era starting
with the time of the disciples and it
goes all the way through to those who
are alive on the earth when Jesus comes
the second time and they focus on
different aspects during the New
Testament era for example the churches
focus on the condition of the church
during the Christian era so the church
went through different phases the early
church was pure they were faithful to
the word then you have the Church of
Smyrna that was a persecuted church and
they were persecuted by P by the Romans
by Pagan Romans and that continued until
the legalization of Christianity in 313
and then you see a compromise begins to
take place throughout the Dark Ages all
the way up until you get to the Church
of the reformation and the truths of
God's word are beginning to be uh
understood and people are studying but
then you get to the sixth Church which
is the Church of Philadelphia and that's
where the verses that you're asking
about the Church of Philadelphia
represents the Christian Church um from
about 1800 maybe a little after that 185
1810 there's no hard date there but
around 1800 through to about
1850 that's roughly the time period and
for the Church of Philadelphia it's very
interesting Jesus uh encourages the
church but he doesn't give any word of
rebuke whereas the other churches all of
them except for Philadelphia and Smyrna
they receive a word of rebuke but
Philadelphia doesn't in other words it
was a good church it was doing the right
thing and if you look in history in the
early 1800s there was a great Revival in
studying the word of God both in theit
un States and around the world the Bible
was translated in more than 1,500
languages Bible societies were
established missionaries went out to
Africa and to Asia and to the furthest
parts of the world there was a great
Revival uh and here this church in the
church Jesus says I will keep you from
the hour the hour of trial that is
coming upon the whole earth well it
wasn't for the Church of Philadelphia to
go through the final Great Tribulation
it's for the next church the church of
leoda a we're living in the time of the
Church of leoda today and according to
Revelation 12:1 it says when Michael
stands up there will be a time of
trouble worse than the world has ever
seen but at that time thy people shall
be delivered everyone found written in
the book so this Great Tribulation that
the Bible speaks about is yet in the
future the church is not raptured away
before the tribulation but they are
preserved through the tribulation just
like the children of Israel when they
were in Egypt when the 10 plagues Came
Upon Egypt the children of is Israel
they were protected from the plagues and
they were delivered out after the
plagues had done their work so likewise
at the end of The Seven Last plagues
Jesus comes and the righteous are
delivered and taken to heaven so that's
the context there if you look at the
seven churches so it's not talking the
Church of Philadelphia is not talking
about a Rapture time period it's rather
talking about the church in history in
the early
1800s Jamie does that make sense and
it's protecting us through that
tribulation and not taking us away from
it that's right and if you look at the
examples in scripture God always
protects these people through trials he
doesn't always deliver them from trials
for example Shadrach Meshach and abedo
they went through the fiery furnace but
Jesus was with them Daniel went through
the Lion's Dan but you know God
protected him so yes the the righteous
will be on the Earth when the plagues
are poured out but they will be
protected and delivered from those
plagues and a wonderful ssal that I
think speaks of this time is Psalm 91
and if you want to read that Psalm talks
about how no plague shall come Nei they
dwelling and it's talking about the
Judgment that'll be coming upon the
Wicked at the end of time all right
Jamie thank you so much for your call
great question we've got Oscar listening
in New York Oscar welcome to Bible
answers live yeah thank you yes sir I in
in Book of Matthew speaks about the tear
and the weat yes now my question my
question is this are he tears those who
say that Jesus is not
Divine or who deny Jesus as God okay so
are the tears those who deny God or say
Jesus is not God yes that could
definitely be part of it really what's
being described here is two groups of
people uh you have those who are the
wheat and you have those who are the
tears the wheat represents those who are
true to God those who are faithful those
who follow the teachings of the Bible
those who are surrendered to him they
are considered the wheat but they are
tears and tears could include those who
claim to be Christians but as you said
they don't follow with their complete
heart they're not fully surrendered but
out of convenience they might consider
themselves a Christian they might even
go to church but their heart is not
right with God they would considered a
tear and then if you read on in the
parable it says the time will come where
God will separate the wheat from the
tears the wheat is gathered and placed
in the barn but the tears are G gathered
and thrown in the fire and then Jesus
says that's the way it's going to be at
the end of the Earth he'll send his
angels and they'll GA gather the
righteous from the Earth but the wicked
will be destroyed with the glory or the
fire of God at the second coming of
Christ so there's a lot of categories
that could make up the tears it's
anybody who denies the truth of Jesus
but also refuses to follow the Bible or
the teachings of Christ or his law that
would also fall into that category of
the tears you know we do have AUD study
guide that talks about the second coming
of Christ and gives a little more
information about this separation
between the wheat and the tears we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks it is called ultimate
deliverance and it's about the second
coming of Christ we'll be happy to send
that to anyone who calls and ask again
that study guide is called ultimate
Deliverance the number to call is 800
835 6747 as for the study guide ultimate
Deliverance you can also dial pound 250
and just say Bible answers live and ask
for that study book guide by name
ultimate Deliverance we'll be able to
send you a digital download thank you
Oscar we've got um Charlene listening in
the Virgin Islands Charlene welcome to
the program hey good evening hi all
right my question is the little black
cloud that elishah saw on Mount Carmel
in his fight with Ahab and the priests
that was a sign that rain was on its way
to end that three-year drought but was
it also The Chariot of angels coming to
pick up Elijah in the same way that the
cloud is a sign of the son of man coming
in Matthew
24 yes well there's there's kind of a
connection between that so the small
Cloud now just to give the context of
the story you have the showdown between
Elijah the true prophet and you have aab
and the prophets of Baal and the people
were invited to mount Carl and at first
Elijah said well you know you offer your
sacrifices to Baal and the god that
answers with fire you know we'll know he
is the true God and of course all day
long they they try to get Baal to pour
down fire but of course Baal is a false
god nothing happens finally Elijah
rebuilds the the altar that have been
broken down he places the sacrifice the
wood water is poured on the altar Elijah
prays the simple prayer fire comes down
and devours the fire those false
prophets are put to death and then there
was a three and a half year drought
leading up to the shown Mount KL then
Elijah goes and he prays because they
need rain and he prays seven times and
finally a small black cloud is seeing on
the Mediterranean and it's making its
way towards uh the land of Israel and
that is a sign that an abundance of rain
is coming and so Elijah runs down and he
tells aab you got to get to the city
actually runs in front of the charot and
there is a massive downpour of rain that
um uh you know just breaks the drought
that was in Israel now is there
significance to that small black cloud
and the and the rain yes in the Bible
the outpouring of the holy spirit is
called the rain the former Reign it
occurred at Pentecost when the Holy
Spirit came upon the disciples and they
were empowered to take the gospel to the
thenn world but there is another
outpouring of the Holy Spirit just
before the close of probation again
calling people to repentance restoring
true worship a special outpouring of the
holy spirit it's described in Revelation
chapter 18 as an angel that comes down
from heaven and the Earth is illuminated
with his glory and he CED with a loud
voice Babylon he's fallen he's fallen
and God will pour out his Spirit upon
his people there will be a great Revival
amongst God's people but it'll also
awaken persecution against them that is
the last proclamation of the Gospel just
before probation closes the seven last
plagues fall and then Jesus comes to
deliver them so Elijah proclaims an
abundance of rain he then faces
persecution by Jezebel he flees out into
the Wilderness but God sustains him his
faith is tested
and then he is delivered he is taken to
heaven without seeing death that is a
parallel of the experience of God's
people in the last days they receive the
latter rign they Proclaim God's last
warning message yes persecution comes
probation closes their faith is tested
but God delivers them and they are
translated to heaven without seeing
death those who are alive at that point
so yes a definite parallel in those two
stories does that make sense Char
Charlene yes all right let's see we got
Cedric listening in flor Cedric welcome
to the program thank you r r how are you
doing today I'm doing well thank
you my question for you my brother is
regarding to um Matthew 27: 24 and 25
okay let me read it for those who are
listening and then ask the question
about it Matthew 27 beginning verse 24
it says when pilate saw that it could
not Prevail at all but rather that a
tumult was Raising he took water he
washed his hands before the multitude
saying I am innocent of the blood of
this just person you see to it and all
the people answered and said his blood
be on us and our children all right and
your question on
that we we should we be careful what we
pray
for well yeah we do want to be careful
of what we pray but uh this was not so
much a prayer from them but declaring
that you know we don't want Jesus even
if it means that his blood is going to
be on us and our children we don't care
we don't want Jesus now of course
unfortunately that was fulfilled that
judgment did come upon those who uh
crucified Christ and upon that
generation 40 years later you had the
Romans in 70 AD that came and surrounded
the city of Jerusalem and by the end of
that Not only was the city completely
destroyed in the temple but thousands
and thousands of Jews were killed and
many more were taken as slaves back to
Rome and Scattered throughout the Roman
Empire so it was a terrible thing now
now why did all those bad things happen
to them well if you reject God's
protection you left the control of God's
enemy the devil and the devil hates
God's people and so when they rejected
Jesus as their Messiah remember when
Jesus looked over Jerusalem he wept he
said oh Jerusalem Jerusalem th that
kills the prophets and those that are
sent unto you a have long to gather you
together even as a hen gathers the
chicks under her wings but you would not
come come as a result of them rejecting
Jesus God's protection was withdrawn and
the Romans Came Upon them and that verse
was very literally fulfilled in the
destruction of Jerusalem in 70 AD and of
course throughout history throughout the
the last 2,000 years it seems as though
the Jewish people have faced all kinds
of persecution and trials now there
doesn't mean that individual Jews of
course they can't be saved individual
doesn't matter whether you're Jew or
Gentile if you receive Jesus you're part
of Abraham's seed and you are saved but
as a but as a nation as a people they
have faced lots of persecution over the
past 2,000 years friends we're taking a
short break but we'll be back with more
Bible
[Music]
questions stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
[Music]
shortly thank you for tuning in to
amazing facts have you ever wanted to
study the teachings of the Bible in an
easy to understand stepbystep way the
amazing facts Bible school offers free
simple to follow lessons that will guide
you through all of the vital teachings
of scripture visit amazing biest
studies.com to sign up for your free
lessons they're available by mail or
online studies are also offered in
multiple
languages unprecedented levels of pain
and suffering in and death extend my
deepest condolences to the victims and
families an increasing concern about
radioactive exposure of members of the
public millions of people believe that
planet Earth is on the verge of some
apocalypse that will plunge the world's
cities into chaos in response thinking
people everywhere are wondering if it
might be a good time to locate their
families outside of the congested
metropolitan areas but how should a
Believer respond how do we address the
need to reach the Lost in the cities
while still enjoying the Practical
benefits of raising a family in the
country in my new book heading for the
hills a beginner's guide to Country
Living I do my best to provide a
Biblical balance in the last 40 years
I've done evangelism in many of the
world's greatest cities while still
maintaining a home up in the hills that
is completely off the grid I'd like to
share with you some of the crucial
things you'll need to know before you
head up for the hill
I'd also like to identify some of the
Practical things you look for in buying
a piece of country land how to develop
water power and a garden all while still
seeking to save the lost this book has
some very valuable information for
anybody that's ever considering country
living order your copy of heading for
the Hills call 8005382583
[Music]
birth of Abraham okay maybe he wasn't in
the room but he was alive and probably
telling stories about his floating Zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of Revelation bible.com
is a free resource where you can explore
major Bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the Bible and
draw closer to God's word go deeper
visit bible.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
83567 47 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live Hello friends welcome back this is
Pastor Jean Ross Pastor Doug is out of
town this evening but this is a live
interactive International Bible study
and so we welcome your Bible questions
if you'd like to call into the program
this evening the number is 800 463 7297
that's 800 463
7297 or just remember 800 God says
that'll bring you here to the studio I'm
also going to give you another number
that is the free resource phone line and
we'll be giving out a number of uh
valuable resources to help you in your
study of the word of God so take
advantage of those free resources we're
going to go to the phone lines our next
caller is Larry listening in Michigan
Larry you're on the air welcome to Bible
answers live hi there Pastor Ross hi
thanks for
calling I got a couple of scriptures if
you could read them for people who might
be driving but it's Matthew 2416
through1 18 and First Kings 17
2-6 all right let me let me look at
Matthew 24:16 here you say 16 to
18 yes okay Jesus speaking he says then
let those who are in Judea flee to the
mountains let him not let him who is on
the housetop not go down to take
anything out of his house and let him
who is in the field not go back to get
his clothes all right and what was the
other verse First Kings 17:
2-6 First Kings 17:2 it says then the
word of the Lord came to him saying get
away from here and turn Eastward and
hide by the Brook cherith which flows
into the Jordan and it will be that you
shall drink from the Brook and I have
commanded the Ravens to feed you there
so he went and did according to the word
of the Lord for he went and stayed by
the Brook cherith which flowed into the
Jordan and the Ravens brought him bread
and meat in the morning bread and meat
in the evening and he drank from the
brook okay and your question about that
we know flesh is actually the fruit not
meat but right um my question is is the
Lord going to take care of us like that
too then when we have to flee yes like
cu
CU um but you know the Israelites didn't
have to worry about changing their
clothes shoes right when the children of
Israel were delivered and taken from
Egypt to the promised land throughout
the Wilderness wanderings God provided
for them both food mana and he also
provided for them all their water it
spoke about water coming from a rock and
here you find God taking care of his
Prophet Elijah uh when he had to flee
out when there was this terrible uh
drought and he was being persecuted by
aab and Jezebel God provided for for him
so likewise at the end of time God is
going to provide for his people uh the
Bible says that your bread and water
shall be sure meaning that God will
provide your needs doesn't mean that
you're going to you know have a 10
course meal every day but your bread and
your water will be sure God will provide
and take care of his people and you know
I'd rather be in the mountains in a
desolate region with bread and water and
with the blessing and the hope of the
second coming then living in a palace
surrounded by all the dainties and then
receive the seven last plagues and end
up losing your eternal life so a little
with God's blessing is much better than
a lot without God's blessing so yes God
promises to provide and take care of us
in that time of trouble does that help
Larry yes it does okay thank you you
know I mentioned a Psalm a little
earlier that is good to read Psalm 91 I
think describes the experience of God's
people during the plagues when they are
poured out and how God will provide for
them and take care of them it's another
wonderful promise in scripture our next
caller is Kim listening in Iowa Kim
Welcome to the program you got a
question I do have a
question I'm not quite sure how to
phrase this I was just wondering if it's
biblical or not to bring your pets into
the sanctuary for your worship service
all right is it okay to bring this is
happening at at your church y now you're
talking about like like uh uh you know
like dogs I guess bringing a pet dog to
church well you know I think in the case
of a service animal uh you know if if a
person is blind and they need a service
animal to to guide them when they come
to church usually those those dogs are
very well trained they've been trained
to be in public places they behave they
quiet they will sit beside the person
and they they serve a very specific
purpose that of guiding a person that
has a disability in this case somebody
that is's blind but just to bring dogs
and cats and birds into the sanctuary
just for the sake of of bringing them to
church I I think we want to be careful
first of all the church is a holy place
and we want to treat it with reverence
uh we don't want to be running around in
the church we got to tell the children
don't don't run in the sanctuary this is
a holy place we usually dress up when we
go to church because we are entering
into the presence of God it's an act of
worship uh we don't talk loudly in the
church Church uh we talk quietly and we
talk reverently because we we are aware
of God's presence so taking all that
into consideration we probably don't
want anything in the church that is
going to distract from the reason why we
are there that of worship and to bring a
pet to church or a dog or some animal
that might bark or others will see it or
children will be distracted by it I
don't I don't think it's a good practice
now if you're doing a children's story
and you're illustrating the children's
story and you bring a little baby chick
in and you know you show the children
the chick and you talk about the animal
or so on but then you take it out that's
probably fine but on a regular basis to
bring your pets to church I would
discourage that I I know sometimes folks
are very attached to the animals and
they want to take them everywhere but
when it comes to church I would say you
know leave them for a couple of hours at
home or in a safe place where they're
taken care of uh that way you're not a
distraction to other people that come to
church uh does that help Kim yeah ites
does thank you so much I appreciate it
all right thanks for your call our next
caller that we have is uh Lynn listening
in
Arizona let's see Lynn welcome to the
program yes thank you hi there Pastor
John hi thanks for
calling a lot of people may not even
observe this but back in when I was
younger and I'm 60 almost well I'm 67
now and uh when I was younger like in my
20s and I I went to church with my
family we were dedicated Christians but
make a long story short on Easter they
celebrated uh three days you know Friday
Saturday Sunday and he rose on Monday
because a lot of businesses I remember
even when I was 20 and younger would
close on Easter Monday and my dad had an
insurance agency and he closed on Good
Friday and Easter Monday for several
years okay and uh what do you say about
that if you look at the you know the
Easter weekend or the Passover if you
look at the biblical record of course
Jesus died on Friday he died about 3:00
in the
afternoon and uh he was then placed in
or he was on the cross and he said he R
around 3:00 I think closer a little
after that Christ died then he was
placed in the Tomb he was there Friday
evening he was there all day Saturday
and then he rose early Sunday
morning um so you know that's the
biblical account and you can of course
read that in the gospels that makes it
pretty clear now what we call Easter
today doesn't exactly fall on those same
days uh because you know dates in the
calendar move from day to day just like
your birthday it moves the 25th of
December moves throughout throughout the
week if it's based on a p on a date on
the calendar but you know the medieval
church was the first to kind of select a
weekend close to the Passover and said
right we going to celebrate Easter on
this weekend and they came up with the
idea of something special on Sunday now
it's probably okay to talk about the
resurrection absolutely and the death of
Christ that is important but knowing the
Bible does it tell us to make those days
holy days the only day holy within that
weekend was the seventh day Sabbath but
that came because of the Ten
Commandments but Friday is not a holy
day neither is Sunday a holy day nor
Monday if you know your calendar first
day of the week starts on Monday but to
remember the the death burial and
resurrection of Christ around the
Passover around Easter time there
there's nothing wrong with that so yeah
if you're going to follow the Bible
Jesus rose on Sunday morning morning
early in the morning as the Bible
says hope that helps Lynn next caller
that we have is Robert listening in
Washington Robert welcome to the program
hello Pastor Ross yeah welcome was
interested in knowing about Revelation
10 10 and 11 I know Revelation is a
specialty of yours I guess I want to
focus on verse 11 although you might
have to explain verse 10 though okay um
I was interested in what it means by you
must prophesy say again about many
people Nations tongues Kings okay great
you might need to talk about verse 10
too sure I'll be happy to yeah let me
give the the background thanks for the
question I do like the Book of
Revelation it's one of my favorites
Revelation chapter 10 you find at the
beginning of the chapter in angel coming
down from heaven the angel has
represents a messenger or a heaven
brought message and he has a little book
that's open in his hand and he sets his
one foot upon the Earth and his other
foot upon the sea and then he lifts his
hand to towards heaven and swears by him
who lives forever and ever who created
the heavens and the things that are
there in the earth and the things that
are there in the sea and the things that
are there in that there should be time
no longer but at the sounding of the
seventh trumpet when the angel begins to
sound then the mystery of God will be
revealed now the whole chapter
Revelation chapter 10 is a description
of a great Advent Awakening that began
in the early 1800s but really culminated
around 1843
1844 when people began to study the
little book of the Prophet Daniel in the
Old Testament and based upon their study
of the little Book of Daniel in
particular Daniel 8:14 they read about
something called
2,300 day prophecy now one prophetic day
equals one literal year and 2,300 days
is literally 2,300 years they also found
in Daniel chapter 9 that the starting
point of the 2300 years was with the
decree to restore and rebuild Jerusalem
which went into effect in
457 BC 457 BC and so they just did the
math and based upon the calculation that
time period would end
1844 1843 they initially thought but
further calculations they realized
1844 well they thought that the
cleansing of the sanctuary that was
spoken of in Daniel 8:14 was the
cleansing of the Earth by fire at the
second coming of Christ so they thought
Jesus was going to come and of course
this led to a great religious Awakening
that's why when you read on in
Revelation chap 10 John is told to take
the little book out of the Angel's hand
which represents the Book of Daniel to
eat it up it would be sweet in his mouth
but it would make his stomach bitter to
eat the book means to study it to
receive it Jeremiah 15:16 says thy words
were found and I did eat them and there
were unto me the joy and the rejoicing
of my heart so to eat the book means to
study it means to receive it but then
after they had that sweet hope of the
soon coming of Christ when Jesus didn't
come as they had expected they were
bitterly disappointed it was only then
that they began to realize that the
cleansing of the sanctuary wasn't Jesus
coming back to the Earth but rather that
Christ was doing his final cleansing
work taking place in heaven called the
Judgment the pre-advent Judgment when a
cleansing work was to take place on the
earth the cleansing of the heart from
sin the cleansing of the church from
error the proclamation of the truths of
scripture that's why you find in verse
11 of of Revelation chapter 10 after the
book is eaten then the message is given
to John and John's playing the part of
these early Advent Believers you must
prophesy again so they began to realize
that their mission wasn't over it had
scarcely begun what was it that they
would to prophesy well you look in
Revelation CH 14 beginning verse 6 you
have what we call the Three Angels
messages the Everlasting gospel that is
to go to Every Nation Kindred tongue and
people saying with a loud voice fear God
give glory to him the hour of his
judgment has come that ties in with what
we reading Daniel and then of course it
talks about Babylon he Fallen we need to
worship the Creator Babylon he fallen
and warns about the beast power and its
Mark so yes Revelation chapter 10 is a
great study I just kind of flew through
it but that gives you the context so it
met its fulfillment around 1843 1844
more specifically if you want to date
for Revelation chap 10 Robert does that
help yeah thank you that makes a lot of
sense all right thanks for calling
next caller that we have Ava Joe in
Georgia Ava Joe welcome to the
program hi good evening Pastor Ross how
are you I'm good thanks for calling um
thank you for having me I've been
listening to you guys and I really
appreciate everything that amazing facts
does for the entire world but my
question is for those that are taken
with god um when Jesus first comes I
know that the Wicked Will perish but
will they be Resurrected for this second
um judgment or do they just remain
perished all right now you talking about
you talking about the righteous when
Jesus comes the second time they are
resurrected and taken to heaven or you
talking about a special Resurrection the
the second the Judgment the second um
this the Judgment of damnation okay all
right yes let me give you the context so
the Bible tells us that when Jesus comes
the second time you've got three
categories of people you got the Dead
you got the dead righteous and you've
got uh the dead unrighteous in their
graves and you've got the living
righteous and you've got the living
Wicked so it may be four categories so
when Jesus comes the second time the
living righteous will be changed in a
moment in a twinkling of an eye they'll
be caught up to meet Jesus in the air
the graves of the righteous dead will be
opened and they will be resurrected with
their Immortal bodies together with the
living righteous they will meet Jesus in
the air and then the wicked Dead who are
in their graves they remain in their
graves but the wicked who are alive when
Jesus comes the second time they are
destroyed with the brightness of Christ
coming so you have the righteous with
Jesus in the air and you have the wicked
all destroyed on Earth then the
righteous go to heaven for a thousand
years according to Revelation CH 20
talks about the Millennium 1,000 year
reign with Christ and the righteous will
be with Jesus in heaven Heaven at the
end of the 10,000 years the New
Jerusalem Revelation 21 the New
Jerusalem comes down from God out of
heaven and it's at that point that Jesus
sets his feet on the Mount of Olives and
it opens up and forms a great valley
that's Zachariah that talks about that
the New Jerusalem comes to rest and then
all the wicked are resurrected
Revelation 20 calls this the second
Resurrection so the righteous are
resurrected at the first resurrection at
the beginning of the Thousand Years and
the wicked are Resurrected that at the
end of the Thousand Years called the
second Resurrection that's what we call
the great white Throne judgment
Revelation CH 20 and then at the end of
that judgment the wicked Mount their
attack upon the New Jerusalem fire comes
down and devours them that is the final
destruction of the wicked otherwise
known as the Lake of Fire it is where
the wicked and the Earth is cleansed
from sin and then Jesus makes a new
heavens and a new Earth so that's kind
of the breakdown of the first
resurrection and the second Resurrection
does that does that make sense yes thank
you so very much all right you're
welcome you know we do have a study
guide that talks about the 1,000 years
it's called a thousand years of peace
and anyone wanting to learn more about
this you read about in Revelation
chapter 20 the number to call for that
is
6747 and you can ask for that study
study guide It's called 1,00 years of
Peace the number again is 800 835
6747 or you can dial pound 250 on your
smartphone and just say Bible anwers
live and ask for it by name a thousand
years of Peace we've got James listening
in Michigan Detroit Michigan James
welcome to Bible answers life uh hello
Pastor Ross how are you and thank you
for taking my call doing well thanks for
calling good um my question is uh was
Satan cast out of Heaven before the
Earth was created or after the Earth was
created
okay um the war in heaven that you read
about in Revelation 12 it says there was
let me just read it it's right here
Revelation 12:7 it says and war broke
out in heaven Michael and his angels
fought with the dragon and the dragon
and his angels fought so there's war in
heaven between Michael Michael is the
prophetic name of Jesus we're not saying
Jesus is an angel Michael just simply
means refers to Jesus in the prophetic
sense so Jesus and his angels fought
with the dragon or Satan and his angels
so one-third of the Angels joined Satan
in his Rebellion against God we know
that from Revelation
12 but eventually the devil was cast out
of heaven and he sort of went around the
universe looking for a place that he
could kind of establish as his
headquarters in his Rebellion against
God right around that time and the Bible
doesn't tell us how much time passed
between the war in heaven and the
creation of Earth it probably wasn't too
long but after the devil and his angels
are cast out of heaven then God creates
planet Earth and the devil looks and
here's Adam and Eve and he thinks wow if
I can only get them to side with me then
I can make the Earth my headquarters and
that's when he came and he appeared as a
serpent in the Garden of Eden of course
you know the story he was able to
deceive Adam and Eve to trust or
distrust God disobey God and to believe
him they were deceived because that
opened up the floodgates of sorrow and
death but God did not abandon mankind of
course the Plan of Redemption also began
through the sacrificing of the Lamb
which ultimately pointed to Jesus that
would take away the sins of the world so
yes uh Satan is cast out of Heaven
before creation we don't know how much
long how much time elapsed but then he
was able to come and uh deceive Adam and
Eve does that help James yes thank you
so much that answered our my question I
appreciate the call and thank you for
amazing facts oh you're welcome thanks
for calling next caller that we have
let's see Glenn in Ohio Glenn welcome to
the program good evening sir thanks for
taking my call absolutely you know as a
young lad I learned a lesson and that is
when reading the Bible if it seems to
run into a conflict I need to remember
that I don't understand that's the
answer to the conflict because there are
no conflicts in the Bible right we're
going to study further but in Reading
Genesis
66 there seems to be a conflict
and I'm just interested in an
explanation something that questions the
omniscience of God let me read the verse
and then let's talk about it says and
the Lord was sorry that he had made man
on the earth and he was grieved in his
heart so your question is he repented he
repented yes um there's different words
that are sometimes used I'm reading from
the new King James if you read the King
James it says that God repented the idea
there meaning that he was sorrowful or
he was pained the word repentance again
depending upon the context where it's
used it's not that God repented from
anything that he did wrong because God's
perfect but pain came to the heart of
God he was sorry when he saw the way man
was treating man because the Bible says
violence filled the Earth and every
imagination of the heart was evil
continually and God was pained he was
sorry about what had happened on the
earth so it's not a regret but he knew
that was coming he did God knows the end
from the beginning and yet he still
allowed it and why did it allow it
because God respects freedom of choice I
mean he knew that when he created Adam
and Eve that they would eventually Rebel
and that it would cost the very life of
his son that Jesus would have to die and
yet God still continued to create man so
freedom is very important to God and why
is freedom so important because God
can't can't accept
worship that is not freely
given God can't accept love that is
forced it has to be
freely given we have to choose but
there's a risk if you love someone and
you give them freedom to choose there's
a risk that they're not always going to
do what you want them to do so even
though God knew that would happen he
still allowed Freedom allowed them to
make their choice but then he pledged
himself to provide a way of Salvation so
that we could live forever
all right next caller that we have is
Daryl listening in uh Canada Daryl
welcome to the
program thank you
Pastor thank you my question is how will
God like if Jesus was to return today
how would God deal with the resurrected
bodies of the babies born and
unborn okay well I think all of the
children that'll be resurrected or maybe
that'll be alive at the second coming of
Christ they along with uh the adults
will receive glorified bodies however
they will receive glorified baby bodies
you might say or glorified teenager
bodies or wherever they are in life so
if it is a baby and the baby receives a
glorified baby body whatever that is of
course we don't know but the child will
grow up Isaiah says that they shall grow
up as calves in the stall and it talks
about children that are playing in the
streets playing with the animals so
there will be children in heaven they'll
probably grow a little bit slower than
they grow here on the Earth but
eventually children will grow up so
it'll be kind of neat to see how these
children grow up in heaven as they learn
in a a perfect environment the presence
of God the presence of the Angels uh
perfect love uh if ever you could choose
where you want to grow up you'd want to
grow up in heaven so yes God is going to
take care of of the babies the children
those who are resurrected when he comes
again uh you know we do have a um a book
that we'll be happy to send anyone
talking about heaven it says Heaven is
it for real that is a free gift we'll
send to anyone who calls and ask the
number is 800 83567 47 that is our
resource phone line you can just ask for
the book Heaven is it for real you can
dial pound 250 on your smartphone and
say Bible answers live and then ask for
that book Heaven is it for real time for
one more caller before we take a break
Angela we got just about a minute uh
what is your question Angela from New
York yes okay so my question is I you
know I believe that Jesus Christ is my
Lord and Savior but my question is why
isn't he in the Old Testament but he's
in the New Testament okay good question
well Jesus is in the Old Testament he is
all over the Old Testament he is
sometimes referred to as the angel of
the Lord the messenger the word angel
means messenger it was Jesus in the
pillar of fire that led the children of
Israel it was Jesus in the type of the
sacrifices the lamb and the priests in
the whole service it was Christ that was
leading his people and so yes Jesus is
in the Old Testament matter of fact all
of the Old Testament prophecies point to
Jesus of course Jesus appeared to Moses
at the burning bush and he gave himself
the name I am that's why Jesus when he
was in the earth he said to the
religious leaders before Abraham was I
am he used that very same name that was
used at the burning bush so yes Jesus is
in the Old Testament in all different
places well those of you are listening
on satellite radio we are going to say
goodbye as we going off satellite radio
just a little earlier before the rest of
the stations for those of you listening
on landbased stations watching on aftv
we'll be right
back thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends and welcome back those who
have stayed by on the various landbased
radio stations also watching on the
internet and on Amazing Facts TV we're
going to take some of your email
questions we want to thank the many who
have sent us questions via email if
you'd like to email us a question just
simply ba questions
amazingfacts.org that's B questions
amazingfacts.org all right Johnny's
asking the question does the principle
of tith apply to gifts received well it
depends the principle that we find in
the Bible is that we are to tithe on our
increase so if we receive a a gift
unexpected gift and uh you know we want
to thank the Lord for that gift it's
appropriate now that doesn't always mean
if it's a tangible thing that somebody
gives you of course you can't tieth on
that a car or whatever it is you might
receive you might wish to give a special
offering at church a love offering in
recognition of the gift that God has
given if it's money that's somebody has
given you yes you are able to tithe on
that so pray for the spirit to lead you
but it's always a a good thing to
recognize God has been the true Giver of
all things and return your tithes to him
all right Siri is asking is it true that
the Ten Commandments are written on
sapphire stone well the Bible doesn't
tell us for sure what type of stone was
used upon which The Ten Commandments are
written we do know in the Bible that
blue the color blue is often associated
with God's law the priests were told to
make a Hem of blue at the border of
their robes and that was to remind them
of the law of God when they wash their
hands and they wash their feet they
would see that that blue and it would
remind them about obedience so blue is
often associated with the law of God was
the Ten Commandments written on sapphire
stone possibly I I you know the Bible's
not absolutely clear on that I think one
day we will know and uh that will become
true all right next question that we
have is the Bible says the wages of sin
is death is it talking about the first
or the second death when the Bible says
the wages of sin is death it's talking
about the second death now the first
death is the death that we die now for
the believer death is described as
asleep in the Bible and when Jesus comes
the righteous are going to be awakened
from that sleep that's why Jesus said
with reference to Lazarus our friend
Lazarus sleepeth when he was actually
dead now true death as the Bible
describes is the death that the wicked
experienced at the end of the Thousand
Years there is no hope of Resurrection
they are forever separated there is a
judgment associated with that final
second death so that is the ultimate
reward for sin that is the wages of sin
which is death friends thank you so much
for joining us here Bible aners live
look forward to talking some more next
week God
[Music]
bless this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please please call us next Sunday
between 700 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific
time to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast call us
at 800
83567 47 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions